avances para proteger a las marsopas en
México en el Golfo de California viven
estas vaquitas marinas en peligro de
extinción cuya protección Lleva más de
un año en manos del trabajo conjunto
entre el gobierno y la organización sin
fines de lucro cycharper la operación
milagro como se ha llamado trata de
compartir información sobre el área
donde viven estos animales para evitar
males mayores por el momento se han
logrado reducir el 70% de las horas de
pesca de los barcos en las zonas donde
están las marsopas cuando la población
tiene pocos individuos los que quedan se
contraen espacialmente en el lugar en el
que se sienten por decirlo
coloquialmente más a gusto el lugar
donde encuentran su alimento y su
hábitat preferido por eso es que el
gobierno estableció esta zona con una
prohibición total de todo tipo de redes
la lucha por la protección de estos
animales no es nueva los esfuerzos por
mantener viva la especie se redoblaron a
partir de 2018 cuando los biólogos
estimaron que solo quedaban entre 6 y 20
la mayor parte de ellas mueren en las
redes de pescadores por lo que ahora la
prioridad es cambiar esa metodología
hemos probado diferentes técnicas y
formas de resolver los problemas a lo
largo de los años y durante muchos años
tiramos de redes Esta es una estrategia
diferente asegurémonos de que las redes
no se sumerjan en el agua y lo que es
más importante que si se sumergen en el
agua solo estarán allí unos minutos la
lucha para salvar a las marsopas
continúa pese a las acusaciones externas
contra el estado mexicano de aplicar una
regulación ineficaz durante años